und vor dem wohnhaus von samer hier in
berlin steht jetzt mein kollege peter
wege peter du konntest mit einigen
menschen die sammer da in dem wohnhaus
kennengelernt haben sprechen was sagen
sie bei ihm ja wir haben unter anderem
mit dem hausmeister des hauses
gesprochen er hat uns halt eben erzählt
das sah oft gewaltbereit und aggressiv
aufgefallen ist außerdem haben andere
nachbarn erzählt dass sie immer wieder
mit lauten schreien und rufen sie hier
aus dem schlaf gerissen hat und deswegen
hier sehr aggressiv und laut aufgetreten
gerade kurz vor seiner tat am dienstag
morgens schon wurde die polizei hier in
diese straße gerufen weil salat a ganz
aufgebracht verwirrt hier über die
straße lief er trommelte wie im wahn auf
autodächer und schrie laut herum der
polizei wurde deswegen hier im salat als
eine verwirrte person gemeldet erkannt
sie kamen am morgen ein erstes mal
hierhin konnten ihn da nicht finden am
nachmittag wurden sie genau deswegen
noch mal gerufen aber auch da konnten
sie ihn hier nicht aufwenden
außerdem soll er vor gut zwei jahren
schon mehrmals gewalttätig geworden sein
so soll er unter anderem august 2018
einen justizvollzugsbeamten vor einem
pflicht vor dem flüchtlingsheim
angegriffen haben da wurde er aber
freigesprochen weil er als nicht
schuldfähig befunden wurde und war auch
schon damals in einer psychiatrie gibt
es bereits mehrere erkenntnisse dazu wie
genau er sich radikalisiert haben soll
ja da lohnt sich vor allen dingen einen
blick auf sein facebook-profil wo er
unter anderem eine moschee gemeinschaft
die moschee gemeinschaft nbs die der
muslimbruderschaft nahestehen soll und
deshalb auch schon vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird gelegt hat außerdem hat
er im internen in den letzten jahren auf
facebook immer mehr radikalislamische
tendenziös radikalislamische sprüche
gepostet und nach unseren informationen
soll er eben das haben wir aus
sicherheitskreisen erfahren
ein kontakt zu einem gefährt ergattern
oder in zwei islamistische gefährder
weil dieser terror fahrt am dienstag
wurden sechs menschen verletzt weißt du
wie es den opfern jetzt geht ja genauso
neben sechs menschen verletzt drei davon
schwer einer von ihnen ist soll ein
feuerwehrmann sein dieser feuerwehrmann
war auf dem nachhauseweg wurde dann von
sabratha auf seinem motorrad angefahren
und schwerst verletzt nun nicht mehr im
künstlichen koma er wurde noch in der
nacht von dienstag auf mittwoch
notoperiert und schwebt nun neben dem
lebensgefahr